bienvenidos a mi presentación de límites
en esta ocasión vamos a empezar con una
pequeña explicación antes de empezar con
los problemas y bueno voy a decir que
tengo el límite y bueno aunque escriba
aquí esta anotación recuerda que en un
segundo te voy a decir que es un límite
pero bueno la forma de escribirlo es la
siguiente el límite cuando x se aproxima
a 2 el límite cuando x se aproxima a 2 d
no sé me voy a tomar la función x
cuadrada el límite cuando x aproximados
de x cuadrada y bueno realmente lo que
estamos diciendo es a qué valor se
aproxima x cuadrada cuando x se aproxima
a 2 y bueno realmente esto es muy
sencillo y podemos verlo en la siguiente
gráfica si por ejemplo por aquí pongo a
mi eje de las 10 y voy a decir que esté
por aquí este es mi eje de las x y es
más vamos a escribirlo este es mi eje y
m y este es mi eje de las x y ahora
imagínate que yo quiero esbozar aquí a
la función x
la función x cuadrada se va a ver más o
menos así ok
más o menos así de lujo y bueno si
nosotros queremos saber qué es lo que
pasa cuando x vale 2 entonces podemos
sustituir el valor de 2 y vamos a
encontrar que fx o james va a valer
bueno pues 2 al cuadrado lo cual es 4 es
decir que estaríamos en este punto de
aquí en el punto en el que x vale 2 y
vale 4 y bueno cuando estoy hablando del
límite cuando x se aproxima a 2 lo que
quiero ver es cómo me aproximados tanto
a la izquierda como a la derecha por
ambos lados es decir por números que son
más pequeños que 2 por la izquierda y
más grandes que 2 por la derecha y lo
que quiero ver es a qué valor se está
aproximando la función x cuadrada aunque
seguramente te estás preguntando por qué
tenemos que aprender este nuevo concepto
si parece ser bastante obvio es decir en
lo que me quiero fijar es en aproximarme
tanto por la izquierda como por la
derecha
a ver si llegamos al mismo valor por lo
tanto si nos acercamos más y más y más
en esta dirección y más y más y más en
esta otra dirección entonces a que se
aproxima esta función bueno pues
esencialmente a 4 no es cierto esto
podemos decir que es igual a 4 porque
cuando nos aproximamos a 2 tanto por la
derecha como por la izquierda nos vamos
al valor de 4 otra forma de verlo sería
pensar que nos estamos acercando a este
punto tanto como por la izquierda como
por la derecha y date cuenta que sobre
esta misma curva al valor al cual nos
acercamos es 4 y seguramente estás
pensando para que introducir este nuevo
concepto porque parece mucho más fácil
que podamos sustituir el valor de 2 aquí
en esta función y decir bueno pues efe
de 2 es lo mismo que 2 al cuadrado lo
cual es 4 esto parece ser una cosa
bastante obvia y bueno para que tú
entiendas mucho mejor para qué sirve
este concepto déjame definir otra nueva
función
voy a llamar a mi nueva función fx y la
voy a definir de la siguiente manera
fx va a ser una función que cuando no
sea dos y bueno mejor déjame ponerlo si
va a tomar el valor de x cuadrada si x
no es 2
x es distinto de 2 ok en todos los casos
en que quizás esté entre 2 bueno va a
valer x cuadrada
pero cuando x valga 2 entonces voy a
decir que fx va a valer 33 si x es igual
a 2 así que aquí tenemos una ligera
variación de esta función que tenemos
justo aquí pero bueno esta es nuestra
nueva fx y ahora déjenme hacerte una
pregunta qué pasa si en esta ocasión
nos tomamos el límite el límite cuando x
cuando x se aproxima se aproxima atiende
y de nuevo me voy a tomar al 2 el límite
cuando x aproximados de esta función
nueva que acabo de decir de ésta
efe de x cuánto vale este límite
ok pues qué te parece si en esta ocasión
intentamos ver cómo se comporta la
gráfica y para eso bueno date cuenta que
de hecho es casi es casi esta gráfica es
esencialmente la misma gráfica solamente
que cambia un poco
así que déjenme hacerlo por aquí voy a
tomarme aquí a mí
james por aquí me voy a tomar a mi eje x
vamos a ponerlo este es mi hija
ok este de aquí es mi eje x de lujo y
bueno ahora voy a escribir a la función
x cuadrada solamente que hay que tener
cuidado cuando x vale 2 así que déjame
tomarme aquí
esta herramienta y vamos a intentar
poner aquí a la función x cuadrada se va
a ver más o menos así o que llegue a
este punto empieza a subir y cuando x
vale 2 cuando x vale 2 voy a poner aquí
un pequeño círculo porque no está
definida justo ahí en esta parte de acá
arriba y después vuelve a subir y a
comportarse como la función cuadrática
como una parábola ahora aquí estamos en
el valor de 2 aquí es cuando x vale 2 y
bueno fx debería de valer 4 aquí
estaríamos en el valor de 4 justo como
pasaba en esta gráfica sin embargo nos
dice y es más déjeme ponerlo así sin
embargo nos dice que vale 3
vale 3 cuando x vale 2 es decir estamos
imaginando que este es mi valor de 3 ok
entonces estamos en un punto tenemos un
punto justo abajo de este círculo que
acabo de poner aquí cuando x vale 2 ok
fx vale 3 es decir esencialmente se
comporta como la función fx es igual a x
cuadrada date cuenta que va exactamente
igual que esta gráfica de aquí va
exactamente igual aquí aquí cuando x
vale 2 pasa algo llegamos a un estilo
vacío a una brecha o podríamos decirle
un hueco llegamos a un hueco y después
pasamos y se sigue comportando
exactamente igual que la función x
cuadrada y de hecho aquí en este hueco
en esta brecha la función nos especifica
que cuando x vale 2 f de x vale 3 que es
justo este punto de equipo así que date
cuenta que esencialmente es la misma
gráfica aquí llegamos a esta brecha a
este vacío a este hueco pero tomamos el
valor de este punto que tenemos justo
aquí abajo y después nos seguimos
misma manera ahora regresemos a nuestra
pregunta original queremos saber cuál es
el límite cuando x se aproxima 2 de esta
función efe de x y si hacemos el mismo
análisis que estábamos haciendo justo
aquí a la izquierda entonces vamos a
fijarnos qué es lo que pasa cuando nos
acercamos a esta función tanto como por
la izquierda es decir con valores que se
vayan acercando al 2 que sean menores
que 2 y bueno date cuenta que esta
función si nos vamos acercando al 2
entonces se aproximaría justo a este
valor que tenemos aquí y si ahora nos
fijamos en los valores cuando x tiende a
2 pero por la derecha es decir por
valores que sean más grandes que 2
entonces nos estaríamos acercando
bajo esta curva a este punto otra vez
que tenemos aquí a este punto que
tenemos aquí nos estaríamos aproximando
y entonces date cuenta que en este caso
si nos aproximamos altos tanto por la
izquierda como por la derecha llegamos a
este valor de aquí pero este valor de
aquí es 4 por lo tanto
puedo decir que el límite cuando x
aproximados de fx que es justo lo que
podemos ver aquí es igual a 4 y date
cuenta que en este caso este límite no
vale lo mismo que lo que vale la función
recuerda que en este caso la función
vale 3 y es más déjame escribirlo en
este caso el límite el límite cuando x
tiende a 2 de esta función
fx no es lo mismo no es lo mismo que f
de 2 y bueno como no es lo mismo voy a
tachar esta igualdad
efe de 2 vale en este caso 3 y el límite
cuando x se aproxima 2 de fx lo acabamos
de ver vale 4 y date cuenta que no es lo
mismo que pasa aquí en este caso el
límite cuando x tiende a 2 de fx si es
exactamente igual al valor de f
si sustituimos me queda 2 al cuadrado en
lo cual es 4 mientras que aquí no lo es
y creo que ahora estamos empezando a ver
porque el límite es un concepto
ligeramente diferente a solamente
evaluar la función en el punto ya que
puedes tener funciones en donde no sé
por cualquier razón en un punto
determinado ya sea que la función no
esté definida o sea del tipo de función
que da saltos para arriba o para abajo
ok pero si te aproximas a ese punto te
puedes aproximar a un valor diferente al
valor de la función en ese punto
ahora esta es una introducción y creo
que con esto te podrás dar una pequeña
idea de qué es un límite en la próxima
presentación daré la introducción de una
manera más matemática hablando de la
definición épsilon delta de un límite
mientras en el siguiente módulo vamos a
intentar hacer un montón de problemas
que impliquen trabajar con límites y
bueno es que creo que entre más
problemas resuelvas más tendrás la
intuición de que es un límite
cuando veamos derivadas o integrales
seguramente entenderás el porqué la
gente inventó los límites para trabajar
con ellos en fin nos vemos en la
siguiente presentación